president biden is in belgium meeting
with our nato g7 and european union
allies they're looking for the best way
to help ukraine without escalating the
war one month into the conflict we're
seeing new signs that ukraine is holding
off russian advances into most of its
major cities and in some cases pushing
back russian troops from positions
they've held holly williams is inside
ukraine and ed o'keefe is with the
president in brussels let's begin with
you so what is the president doing this
morning
well vlad good to see you he's here at
nato headquarters meeting with the
leaders of the 29 other member nations
later he'll meet with leaders of the g7
and the european council all of this
designed to send a strong message of
defiance to russia's president vladimir
putin
we are united in condemning the
kremlin's unprovoked aggression
and in our support for ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
an extraordinary show of unity at nato
headquarters in belgium as the 30 member
states are here for their first
face-to-face talks about russian
aggression in ukraine this summit is set
to feature an address by ukrainian
president vladimir zielinski a major
test for the alliance as it grapples
with how to appropriately respond to the
invasion of his country which isn't a
nato member
nato's chief announced wednesday the
alliance is doubling its troop
deployment along its eastern flank
sending four new battle groups to
bulgaria hungary romania and slovakia
and today members are expected to agree
on even more for ukraine including
increased cyber security support and
equipment to protect against chemical
biological radiological and nuclear
threats
a white house official tells cbs news
that president biden's package of 800
million dollars in military assistance
to ukraine including anti-aircraft and
anti-tank systems began arriving in the
country on wednesday
and this state department now formally
believes russian forces have committed
war crimes in ukraine expressing
solidarity it's not enough so from nato
we expect that there would be
the pledge that nato will stand by
ukraine ukraine's ambassador tornado
told us yesterday she expects president
zielinski's message to the alliance will
be tough
and direct let us
make brave decisions now because this is
the time where is the issue of other
countries survival is at stake so in
essence his message to nato is do more
and do it faster absolutely
also on the agenda today new sanctions
expected against members of russia's
parliament and amid all the talk of new
nato force deployments we may get a
sense of how many more american troops
will be redeployed or sent here to
europe
nate
o'keefe in brussels thank you